diese brücken sind einzigartige
konstruktionen sie bewegen
jede von ihnen setzt in ihrer zeit ein
technologisches ausrufezeichen die
spektakulärsten beweglichen brücken
dieser wäldchen gleichzeitig
baudenkmäler und infrastruktur ihre
technik macht sie zu unverzichtbaren
bestandteilen wichtiger verkehrswege
weil sie ständig hunderte tonnen ihrer
konstruktionen bewegen müssen sind sie
allerdings enorm wartungsintensiv
ohne dass sie eher wäre es einfach nur
eine straße
die bewegungs mechanik ist technisch
enorm aufwendig bewegliche brücken
müssen ständig gewartet werden diese
konstruktionen sind fast immer sehr
gewagte unikate
es dürfte keine aufbauten auf der
uferpromenade geben gar nichts schule
ist eine gewaltige herausforderung
als ingenieur war ich sehr skeptisch
ein multimillionen spiel das die
brückenbauer nicht selten an den rand
der verzweiflung treibt
wirklich ambitionierte und zu seiner
zeit auch sehr teurer plan
beim bau dieser brücken müssen die
ingenieure neue wege gehen grenzen
überschreiten
aber wenn sie fertig sind und täglich
vielen menschen neue wege eröffnen haben
sich aufwand und risiko gelohnt
das ist toll
bewegliche brücken die geheimnisse ihrer
ausgeklügelten technik die
schwierigkeiten beim bau und die
tägliche herausforderung der wartung
dies sind
spektakuläre konstruktion
bewegliche brücken
[Musik]
majestätisch
gigantisch
[Musik]
einzigartig
die superlative haben ihre berechtigung
diese brücken wehren allerdings nicht
vorstellbar ohne einige entscheidende
meilensteine in der geschichte des
brückenbaus
[Musik]
bewegliche brücken sind schon im
mittelalter bekannt zu brücken an
festungen und stadttouren bieten schutz
vor feinden die ersten echten
beweglichen brücken werden zur
überquerung von fahrerinnen und in
hafenanlagen gebaut ihre besonderheit
sie können als ganzes oder in teilen
bewegt werden bauarten gibt es viele
alte häufigsten klappbrücke zweckmäßig
aber mechanisch höchst anspruchsvoll
ende des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts werden
die brücken kreativer und ausgefeilt hat
highlights sind die kib brücke in games
hält und die hupe in bordeaux
dies ist die kaiser-wilhelm-brücke in
wilhelmshaven europas größte und älteste
doppel drehbrücke
[Musik]
gebaut wurde sie von 1905 bis 1907
kostenpunkt 1,6 millionen goldmark
die brücke übersteht beide weltkriege
und das als verbindung zu deutschlands
größtem marina haben
sie arbeitet immer noch nach dem
ursprünglichen antriebs prinzip von 1907
die mechanik bewegt knapp 440 tonnen
stahl und öffnet damit bei wind und
wetter einen weg für durchfahrende
schiffe eine meisterleistung der
ingenieurskunst
der antrieb sitzt unter den
brückenpfeilern rüdiger mal ist der
wartungs chef und arbeitet schon seit
1981 hier
vor allem das dreh werk muss jeden tag
gepflegt werden der mechanismus der die
jeweiligen brücken flügel bewegt
anfänglich öffnete der brücken wird die
konstruktion noch mit reiner muskelkraft
seit 1909 treibt ein elektromotor das
dreh werk an ja es wirklich
beeindruckend das damals schon solche
leistungen erbracht wurde wenn man
wollte ich dass die ganzen brückenbogen
und die pylone hier auf der landseite
oder teilweise vor ort mit dampf noch
genietet wurden das
unvorstellbaren etwas dafür sachen wir
die freundin
heute steht eine wichtige wartung an
die nahtstelle in der brückenmitte muss
gecheckt werden kollege coups kann über
ein zentral pult beide flügel an steuern
damit man die nahtstellen kommt muss er
die brücke etwas öffnen
hunderte tonnen stahl setzen sich in
bewegung
die beiden drei werke unter den 20 meter
hohen pfeilern in der mitte der beiden
flügel sind mehr als 100 jahre alt
die kaiser wilhelm brücke hat eine
spannweite von
159 und einer breite von acht metern sie
wiegt 440 tonnen die beiden pylone sind
gut 20 meter hoch wenn die brücke sich
bewegt werden die brücken flügel von der
verkehrslage in die betriebslage gesetzt
dabei werden die stütz lager entlastet
und die kräfte während des druckvorgangs
auf den sogenannten königsstuhl und die
laufräder abgeleitet
rüdiger mal kontrolliert die nahtstelle
der brücke wenn sie ihre flügel öffnen
sollen hier vier zapfen auseinander
gleiten damit das auch bei den starken
nordsee finden und druck auf die
tonnenschweren brücken flügel klappt
müssen die zapfen gut gefettet seien
so kann es wieder einfahren
die brücke schließt sich langsam wieder
die zapfen greifen ineinander
ein stahlkoloss der sich zentimetergenau
bewegt seit mehr als einem jahrhundert
haben
ungethüm dank
dieses ungetüm arbeitet mit alter aber
verlässlicher mechanik
dass drei werks getriebe besteht aus
mehreren teilen vier räder zweirad wagen
sowie zwei stütz rollen verteilen die
last und öffnen die brücken flügel
mit dem flotten programm des
kaiserreichs wird wilhelmshaven zu
deutschlands wichtigsten
marinestützpunkt und für die sperrigen
kriegsschiffe braucht der stützpunkt
einer drehbrücke der ingenieur oliver
leinert leitet 2010 die sanierung der
brücke und kennt ihre geschichte ganz
genau der stahl- und viele
baumaterialien kamen per schiff und
wurden dann hier auf einem lehr gerüst
einem holzgerüst zusammengebaut genietet
wie so ein stecksystem
denn als die brücke gebaut wurde war der
hafen auch in bau hier da war noch kein
wasser soll er also im grunde auf land
gebaut den auftrag die größte drehbrücke
europas zu bauen bekommen die brücken
erprobten steinbauer der firma mbn werk
gustavsburg beim 1 in nur zwei jahren
bauzeit vollenden
die stahlkonstruktion diese muss
möglichst filigran gehalten sein um den
starken nordsee finden keine zu großen
angriffsflächen zu bieten doch im laufe
der jahre ist nicht nur die raue
witterung eine gefahr für die brücke das
glück dass sie zwei weltkriege überlebt
hat das ist so man hat bei der sanierung
die zwei weltkriege auch deutlich
angesehen rund 100 luftangriffe auf
wilhelmshaven übersteht die brücke nach
1945 wollen die englischen besatzer sie
demontieren und den begehrten stahl nach
england abtransportieren doch die
wilhelmshaven aber halten ihr
wahrzeichen reparieren die schäden und
auch heute mehr als 70 jahre später ist
die brücke noch unerlässlich für den
straßen und im schiffsverkehr
die kaiser-wilhelm-brücke ist ein sehr
lebendiges denkmal mehrmals täglich
öffnet sie ihre flügel immer wenn ein
schiff mit mehr als acht meter höhe
durch will die männer steuern alles von
central pult auf dem südlichen flügel
ein marine schlepper will in den hafen
einfahren jeder eröffnung ist die brücke
für den autoverkehr gesperrt deshalb ist
eile geboten
rüdiger mal behält die automatische
bewegung der brücke genau im blick
die steuerung kann ja auch mal
versuchen und
ich muss jetzt darauf achten dass wir
gleich in ihnen vielleicht gehen
ein heikler moment die drehbewegung muss
kurz vor der vollen öffnung langsamer
werden und von selber stoppen
die flügel sind in 90 grad stellung zum
stehen gekommen platz genug für eine
sichere durchfahrt des marine schleppers
beim schließen wird sich zeigen ob die
wartungsarbeiten vom morgen erfolgreich
waren
seit der sanierung vor einigen jahren
arbeitet die brücke wieder anstandslos
bis zu windstärke acht
die kann schon richtig gut
spielt dann ihre musik in unten in den
wind verbänden beistand der wind durch
sämtliche tonlagen
nach zehn minuten ist der marine
schlecker durch und die wilhelmshaven
haben ihre kaiser wilhelm brücke wieder
ein stählernes wahrzeichen eine ikone
unter den beweglichen brücken
eine ebensolche ikone die es bis zum
wahrzeichen einer weltstadt gebracht hat
steht in den usa
chicago die stadt der klappbrücke
[Musik]
gleich 38 solcher brücken überspannen
den chicago river für die einheimischen
ist aber nur eine die königin der brücke
ich liebe ihre geschichte sie liegt
genau auf der matschigen der
bekanntesten straße chicagos die
michigan avenue bridge ein wahrzeichen
der welt statt sie hat der stadt in den
20er jahren leben eingehaucht
wir starten sie jetzt
dank der club- mechanismen ist der
chicago river selbst für große
segelboote befahrbar denn dieser mythos
lebt und arbeitet
seit 1991 steht die brücke unter
denkmalschutz
erbaut von 1918 bis 1920 kostete die
brücke 1,8 millionen dollar
die michigan avenue bridge verbindet die
wichtigsten teile chicago
chefingenieur den berg von der
verkehrsbehörde weiß wie skeptisch viele
dem projekt gegenüber standen
[Musik]
es war ein wirklich ambitionierte und zu
dieser zeit auch sehr teurer plan es war
ein ständiges hin und her der erste
antrag ging nicht auf
sie haben zwei anläufe gebraucht und
alle an bord
die leute verstehen heute aber wie
wichtig es für unsere stadt war das ist
unser
die brücke hat einen doppelten
klappmechanismus beide seiten können
unabhängig voneinander platz für schiffe
machen
2009 wird die brücke aufwendig
restauriert heute überqueren jeden tag
knapp 50.000 fahrzeuge das historische
bauwerk
die leute die die brücke die seiten
haben sehr weit vorausgedacht sie ist
sehr robust sie kommt mit den hohen
belastungen von heute klar und kann
sicher noch viel mehr schaffen
eine unverwüstliche bewegliche brücke
für chicago schon kurz nach der
eröffnung
unverzichtbar denn wenn die michigan
avenue verstopft ist droht chaos in der
ganzen stadt die eigentliche
herausforderung ist das ein jahrhundert
alte innenleben alle zahnräder und
motorteile sind einzelanfertigungen
echte unikate
geht etwas kaputt muss es aufwendig
erneuert werden und die brücke fällt aus
im regelbetrieb öffnen sie sich jeden
mittwoch und samstag für den
schiffsverkehr
[Musik]
um den reibungslosen betrieb kümmert
sich herrn zwei-mann-team james half men
von edwin rodrigues
die beiden kontrollieren regelmäßig ob
die brücken motoren einsatzbereit sind
wir müssen alle verbindungsstellen
kontrollieren alle beweglichen teile
einschnitt genau das machen wir jetzt
sobald der startknopf gedrückt ist
treibt der motor diese zahnräder an er
ist das kleinste dann alle größeren eine
art kettenreaktion
nichts darf klemmen reichlich öl
schmiere ist deshalb unerlässlich
das ist der schlüssel für das öffnen der
brücke ohne das hier ist es einfach nur
eine straße erst diese räder machen sie
tatsächlich zur brücke
die größten feinde der brücke
feuchtigkeit frost und hitze
verschleiß erscheinungen sind nach 100
jahren keine seltenheit des wird müssen
die arbeiter jederzeit aufmerksam und
sorgfältig vorgehen
der chicago river ist für schiffe und
boote wichtig als verbindung zwischen
den großen seen und dem mississippi
die stadt chicago ist sehr eben die
fahrbahnen der brücken über den fluss
liegen für viele schiffe zu niedrig das
stellt ein erhebliches problem dar
die lösung klappt brücken wie an der
michigan avenue
chefingenieur william m er schafft hier
1920 die erste klappbrücke mit zwei
fahrbahnen übereinander eine
doppeldecker klampen ein motor setzt die
zahnräder in gang ein gegengewicht sorgt
mit einem hebel mechanismus dafür dass
die brücke aufklappt
auch heute ist es wieder soweit die
brücke soll sich in kürze öffnen die
ersten boote warten schon
kevin ist der mann der die
entscheidenden knöpfe drückt oben im
beobachtungs turm ist volle
konzentration gefragt immerhin
entscheidet setzen wer wann fahren darf
oder warten muss beliebt macht er sich
damit nicht immer
[Musik]
manchmal springen leute über die
absperrung ich habe schon gesehen dass
sie da unten streiten weil sie warten
müssen
mal sehen ob heute alles friedlich
bleibt
[Musik]
drücke geht hoch bleiben sie hinter der
absperrung
während der eröffnung ist der reguläre
verkehr auf der michigan avenue eine
viertelstunde lang komplett lahmgelegt
ok los gehts wir fangen an
[Musik]
wenn nicht gerade ganz große boote durch
wollen fährt kevin meist nur einen
flügel hoch aber auch dass zelebriert er
michigan ist in der luft alles oben wir
warten jetzt auf die boote
je nach saison durchfahren manchmal
mehrere hundert segelboote die haupt
wasserstraße
danach bringt kevin den auto und
fußgängerverkehr so schnell wie möglich
wieder in gang
[Musik]
[Applaus]
alles muss perfekt koordiniert seien
jeder sorgt dafür dass seien teil der
operation funktioniert
genau diese verantwortung für ein großes
ganzes macht die faszination dieses jobs
aus
[Musik]
ich bin hier geboren und aufgewachsen
ein teil hiervon zu sein macht mich
stolz darauf
wenn ich mich hier zum beispiel schneide
weiß ich ich blute für meine stadt
[Musik]
die herr rainer zweckmäßigkeit werden
lang doch mit der jahrtausendwende
beginnt bei den beweglichen brücken eine
völlig neue evolutionsstufe
spektakulär und zugleich elegant
riesengroß und auch filigran heißt es
nun
die gateshead millennium bridge
verbindet zwei städte auf eine bisher
nie dagewesene weise
[Musik]
sie ist die einzige kitt brücke der welt
die sich um ihre längsachse dreht
enorm starke hydraulikzylinder schieben
die konstruktion bei bedarf aus ihrer
ruhe position
und machen so den weg für schiffe frei
[Musik]
nach drei jahren bauzeit wird die brücke
2001 eröffnet baukosten 22 millionen
pfund die brücke im nordosten von
england verbindet die städte gateshead
und newcastle tony hawk's will ist britt
master der gate millennium bridge in
wenigen stunden soll sich die brücke
öffnen das klingt nach viel zeit doch
noch sind wartungsarbeiten in vollem
gange hallo jungs hallo
wie geht's mit den ventilen voran
klappt das mit der reinigung ja sehr gut
wie viele ventile habt ihr noch noch
wartungs ingenieur luca de rosa muss
ölwechseln ventile reinigen und alles
wieder abdichten für die große
inspektion braucht er mehrere tage
das ist die grosse wartung sehr
aufwendig wir machen das nur alle fünf
bis sechs jahre kommt auf die
verschmutzung an
die männer sind jetzt beim letzten
ventil
toni ist ungeduldig vor der nächsten
öffnung wieder wissen ob die hydraulik
dicht ist
ein testlauf soll zeigen ob das system
einsatzbereit ist
[Musik]
luca verlässt sich beim test auf sein
gehör
toni auf seine hände
[Musik]
ich überprüfe gerade den ölfluss hier
hinten an diesem ventil um zu sehen ob
alles gut läuft
man kann das anhand der vibrationen gut
feststellen
die games hört millennium bridge ist
nicht die erste brücke der welt die mit
hydraulik geöffnet wird aber sie ist die
erste bei der die technik komplett
verborgen ist
die fundamente aus 19.000 tonnen beton
liegen tief im flussbett sie geben dem
fußgängerbereich dem sogenannten dect
halt und dem riesigen bogen der das
gegengewicht zum deck bildet das
herzstück der konstruktion ist die
riesige hydraulikanlage sie lässt die
brücke um die längsachse zwischen den
anker punkte notieren öffnet sich die
brücke halten sich deck und bogen die
waage
das londoner architektenbüro will
konnten
hier hat diese brücken revolution ihren
ursprung vielleicht liegt es daran dass
es für architekt gem der allererste
brücken entwurf überhaupt ist wir
durften überhaupt nichts auf die
uferpromenade bauen gar nichts
die ganze konstruktion musste in den
fluss passen ich erinnere mich wie ich
gedacht habe dass ein geschwungenes deck
sich gerade weit genug öffnen müsste um
genügend durchfahrtshöhe zu bieten
normalerweise überqueren die passanten
das deck 5 meter über dem fluss doch
luka und toni wollen die brücke gleich
auf 25 meter kippen bis dahin ist noch
einiges zu tun
das ist nicht gerade der beste job aber
jemand muss ihn ja machen
auf geht's
die beiden müssen die riesigen
hydraulikzylinder auf der anderen seite
der brücke schmieren du kannst jetzt
pumpen aber
die pumpe ist noch nicht einsatzbereit
ich habe ja gar keinen druck mehr
[Musik]
manchmal verlierst du druck wenn der
vorstand niedrig ist
dann musste mit der hand dran
wenn es um das wohl seiner brücken geht
ist sie tony für keine arbeit zu schade
[Musik]
nun wir schmieren die lager einmal im
jahr wir geben ihnen einen guten schuss
vor dem sommer weil die brücke da drei
bis vier mal pro tag auf und zu geht
mit dem fed bleibt alles tiptop
toni arbeitet seit über 12 jahren an der
gates hält millennium bridge
[Musik]
als die komplett vorgefertigte brücke im
november 2000 angeliefert wird erleben
die beiden städte eine logistische
meisterleistung
der größte schwimmkran europas nahmen
station hörchens stimmt die
mammut-aufgabe
es war eine sehr aufregende zeit als die
brücke eingebaut wurde
das wetter muss
sie konnten keinen wind gebrauchen weil
sie sonst hin und her schwingen würde
wir folgten der brücke und foren immer
wieder in richtung fluss um blicke zu
erhaschen wie die brücke der hochburg
das zu sehen war ziemlich surreal
die männer auf dem kran haben nur wenig
wasser unter dem kiel sie müssen gegen
die apple arbeiten und den 126 meter
langen und 45 meter hohen bogen
zentimetergenau in position bringen
es kamen so viele leute um das zu sehen
mindestens 30.000 menschen wollten sehen
wie die brücke eingebaut wird und dann
nochmal zur eröffnung das war schon ein
ganz besonderer tag
zeit für die nächste eröffnung der
brücke dafür schließt toni zuerst die
zugänge
das ausflugsschiff fortuna will
flussaufwärts fahren
[Musik]
wir geben beschied wenn wir loslegen wir
sollten aber pünktlich sein
vielen dank
die fußgänger müssen jetzt runter von
der brücke
guten morgen ladies and gentlemen
herzlich willkommen zur zeit millennium
bridge die brücke wird bald kippen jeder
der die brücke rüber will bitte jetzt
das ist der letzte aufruf
machen sie bitte die brücke frei
[Musik]
über 800 tonnen stahl sollen sich gleich
in bewegung setzen luka und toni sind
nervös
[Musik]
das system ist zwar nicht aber wird es
auch synchron arbeiten auf beiden seiten
der brücke schieben jeweils drei
hydraulikzylinder die konstruktion in
die waagerechte
für die bevorstehende passage der
fortuna hat toni keine augen ihn
beschäftigen die anzeigen auf dem
bildschirm
[Musik]
alles läuft gut
wir beobachten die auslenkung der
zylinder stangen
die müssen auf beiden seiten genau
gleich weit heraus waren deswegen
schauen wir uns jetzt die druck und
ölfluss parameter
bei einer differenz von nur elf
millimetern hält die brücke aus
sicherheitsgründen automatisch an und
wäre dann längere zeit für jeden verkehr
gesperrt
viereinhalb minuten dauert das kippen
der sogenannte tilt dann ist die brücke
geöffnet das deck ist nun 45 grad
geneigt
[Musik]
die fortuna kann passieren
toni ist immer noch angespannt denn die
brücke muss ja wieder schließen
die druckzylinder liegen schön frei
ich überprüfe das nur zur sicherheit
weil er gerade diese wartungsarbeiten
hatten
die brücke kam wieder zurück in normal
position schwingen
toni gibt sie für die fußgänger frei
vielen dank ladies and gentlemen bitte
öffnen sie die tore
[Musik]
jetzt hatte den stress erst mal hinter
sich
[Musik]
es ist so gut gelaufen ich bin
überwältigt
manchmal zieht sie ein bisschen aber das
war einfach nur perfekt
ich bin zufrieden
an der geld hält millennium bridge neigt
sich ein langer tag dem ende zu ein
letzter kontrollgang und toni kroos will
verabschiedet sich in den feierabend
[Musik]
die gateshead millennium bridge ist
einzigartig aber es gibt noch mehr
ungewöhnliche brücken in frankreich
steht ebenfalls ein absolutes unikat
der pogues april muss
das bauwerk benannt nach einem politiker
ist die größte hubbrücke europas ein
meisterwerk der technik auf seine art
einmalig der entwurf stammt von michael
virologie und dem architektenbüro von
thomas ley wie nie seit 2013 ist die
brücke in betrieb gekostet hat sie knapp
157 millionen euro
die gagfah bahn dermaßen brücke liegt in
bordeaux im südwesten frankreichs
[Musik]
die brücke überspannt den fluss garonne
sie ist vor allem für den autoverkehr
ausgelegt verfügt aber auch über
abgesetzte rad und fußgängerweg
[Musik]
[Applaus]
für die meisten schiffe ist die breite
passage in der mitte hoch genug aber
eben nicht für alle
[Applaus]
[Musik]
für richtig große schiffe wird das
mittlere brückenteil zur hubbühne in
jedem der vier türme steckt eine
seilkonstruktion mit deren hilfe das
2500 tonnen schwere mittelstück nach
oben gezogen wird
in wenigen stunden steht die nächste
schiffspassage an
sebastian wifo ist für die technik in
der brücke verantwortlich
[Musik]
motoren getriebe maschinen die ganze hob
technik steckt hier tief unten in den
final das scheint naheliegend ist es
aber keineswegs
das ist der unterschied zu den
klassischen rubriken
der powershell bordell mars ist ein
prototyp oder die einzige brücke dieser
kategorie bei der die motoren unten
eingebaut sind und nicht oben an den
pfeilern die laster mittwoch zu ziehen
die konstrukteure wenden das prinzip des
fahrstuhls an den 2500 tonnen der bühne
stehen innerhalb der pylone vier massive
gegengewichte von insgesamt 2400 tonnen
gegenüber die sich gegenläufig zu
hubbühne bewegen
[Musik]
massive umlenkrollen verteilen die last
auf insgesamt elf stahlkabel probt einer
[Musik]
die kabel stehen unter gewaltiger
spannung
alle drei monate werden die stahlkabel
hiervon industriekletterer kontrolliert
und gefettet sie sichern sich und lassen
sich dann hinab um die kabel meter für
meter in augenschein zu nehmen so
garantieren sie deren betriebssicherheit
sowohl bei dem antriebsstrang hier als
auch bei den spann kabel
jeder turm fungiert als gigantischer
aufzugsschacht
die gegengewichte übernehmen den
hauptteil der notwendigen arbeit um die
brücke anzuheben den rest erledigen zwei
elektromotoren mit jeweils 180 ps
doch das manöver ist kein selbstläufer
wir müssen die brücke jetzt verlassen
heute abend steht eine schiffspassage an
wir müssen noch vorbereitungen treffen
damit auch wirklich alles funktioniert
der ganze aufwand wird eigentlich nur
für kreuzfahrtschiffe wie die silver
explorer getrieben
solche schiffe sollen an der altstadt
von bordeaux anlegen können und dafür
ist die bewegliche brücke die
voraussetzung
auch wenn die brücke heute ein
wahrzeichen von bordeaux ist für den bau
verantwortliche wie michelle geschenk
erinnern sich noch wie viel widerstand
es in der planungsphase gab
für die gegner war die höhe ein problem
motto ist eine sehr flache statt man
musste die brücke aber sehr hoch bauen
das zu akzeptieren war nicht einfach
doch der praktische nutzen der brücke
ist groß mal abgesehen von der hub
funktion
wo du wächst von jahr zu jahr immer neue
stadtviertel entstehen die brücke
verbindet sie und entlastet vor allem
das straßennetz der innenstadt das
ehrgeizige konstrukt wird in nur drei
jahren an bord
[Musik]
viele teile kommen vorgefertigt weil auf
der baustelle platzmangel herrscht
spektakulärster moment ist die
anlieferung der 117 meter langen
hubbühne
zur eröffnung kommt staatspräsident
francois hollande
der porsche abonnements verbindet
mehrere viertel auf eine verträgliche
weise wir wollten eine belebte brücke
auf der man spazieren gehen kann die von
autos fußgängern und radfahrern
gleichermaßen genutzt werden kann und
die ein sinnbild der neuen stadt ist
gleich müssen die bürger für kurze zeit
auf ihre brücke verzichten der hub steht
an
sebastian gefeilt zudem eigens für die
brücke eingerichteten kontrollturm
für autos geht jetzt nichts mehr auch
alle fußgänger müssen die brücke
verlassen die zeit drängt das schiff
fährt gleich ab legen
auch bei der ersten öffnung der brücke
herrscht im kontrollraum höchste
anspannung hallo hafen hallo hafen könnt
ihr uns helfen
wir wollen anfangen
wenn alle fußgänger durch sind heben wir
die brücke
gute fahrt
das problem es sind immer noch menschen
auf der brücke und das obwohl das
kreuzfahrtschiff schon auf dem weg ist
[Musik]
das heben verzögert sich und die
ingenieure im kontrollraum werden nervös
eigentlich wollten sie längst den hub
mechanismus auslösen per fußschalter
doch noch immer sind passanten auf der
brücke
endlich die brücke ist geräumt es geht
los
erst 15 sekunden nach dem start signal
setzt sich die hubbühne million knacken
in bewegung
2500 tonnen stahl steigen in die höhe
[Musik]
die bahn alle parameter sind im grünen
bereich die brücke ist jetzt oben das
schiff kann durch
jede hub ist ein ereignis ein pro jahr
wollen nur etwa 50 bis 60
kreuzfahrtschiffe nach bordeaux
alles geht gut die silver explorer
passiert sicher den durchlass nach oben
ist noch viel platz es können also auch
deutlich größere schiffe bordeaux
ansteuern
das ist keine routine hier wenn es dazu
wird dann verlieren wir die kontrolle
das wichtigste ist für uns den zeitplan
einhalten das ist unser leitprinzip die
zeit steht im mittelpunkt
das schiff war zeitig drin die männer
können die brücke früher als geplant
wieder herablassen
elf minuten dauert das manöver dann
haben sebastian leto und seine kuh feier
am
endlich durchatmen bis zum nächsten coup
die bürger von bordeaux haben ihre
spektakuläre burkl wieder
die engländer haben sogar eine brücke
die man selbst dann begehen kann wenn
sie für den schiffsverkehr geöffnet wird
denn dieses cambridge ist die einzige
bewegliche brücke der welt die nicht
gesperrt wird wenn sie fährt die brücke
erinnert an einen tarnkappenbomber und
ist in vielerlei hinsicht
außergewöhnlich
2013 eröffnet kostete die 35 meter lange
brücke rund sieben millionen britische
pfund die skyline ridge befindet sich in
der stadt kingston upon hull im norden
von england und überspannt den fluss
hall
weltweit einmalig die brücke bleibt
während der drehung für fußgänger
geöffnet
die brücke animiert passanten geradezu
mit zu fahren wenn sie sich in bewegung
setzt
[Musik]
und das funktioniert so ein glockenspiel
kündigt das nächste manöver an passanten
betreten die brücke während sie sich
dreht er aus der altstadt kommt kann
jederzeit zu steigen der über 350 tonnen
schwere ausleger nimmt während der
rotation bis zu 1000 menschen auf
100 sekunden dauert die fahrt dann
öffnen sich die sperren am
gegenüberliegenden ufer wieder
schiffe können den fluss nur bei flut
befahren jetzt ist gerade apple und
damit der richtige zeitpunkt um die scan
lionbridge einer wartung zu unterziehen
denn in sechs stunden muss sie sich für
ein tankschiff öffnen
der brücken techniker wales und sein
lehrling henry wollen die zeit bis zum
nächsten manöver unbedingt nutzen
lasst uns die rhönräder checken und
schmieren und auch nach dem
hydraulischen
dafür klettern die beiden ins fundament
der brücke hinab hier unten steckt der
drehmechanismus
hier liegen lappen und ein schaber
olver und rollbahn sind nicht
abgekapselt und somit staub und dreck
ausgesetzt
die holborn hier liegt eine rostige
schrauben ja ich sehe es ja ich nehme
sie weg und hier mal sauber wischen
[Musik]
schmierfett in verbindung mit sand und
dreck das ist gift für den sensiblen
rolle mechanismus die männer müssen
öfter als geplant zur wartung antreten
und erleben dabei immer wieder
überraschungen
ich muss zugeben das ist das erste
fledermaus nest das sich hier unten
bemerken wenn die sich jetzt die
reinsten bekommen wir probleme das
müssen wir im auge behalten und sofort
weg schaffen
sauber halten und schmieren ist aber
nicht alles der 350 tonnen schwere
ausleger und das gegengewicht lasten
direkt auf den rädern und der rollbahn
offenbar zu viel last für die schrauben
die die rollbahn fixieren sollen kannst
du die schraube da hinten noch mal
checken der ist locker die rollbahn darf
sich nicht locker
bei dieser inspektion zeigt sich dass
neil und henry in zukunft öfter kommen
lassen
normalerweise kommen wir zweimal im jahr
dann ist alles ganz trocken und die
brücke macht geräusche
und sie bewegt sich nicht mehr
geschmeidig das müssen wir dann
denn die scale wayne bridge dient auch
als touristenattraktion und auf und gibt
es in hall nicht besonders viele
planungen zum bau gibt es schon 2008
aber wegen diverser verzögerungen wird
die brücke erst 2013 fertig gestellt
doch nicht nur die konstruktion ist
einmalig die scale wayne bridge hat
außerdem ein exklusives
lichtkonzept und ein eigenes soundsystem
[Musik]
in der planungsphase hat die brücke
viele gegner gerade der vielen features
wegen unserer ihnen wollten ingenieur
peter carey
als ingenieur war schon sehr skeptisch
wegen dem ganzen kunst kann die lichter
der sound durch ihren viel zu viel zu
sein aber ich habe als ingenieur die
baustelle lange jahre überwacht und als
sie fertig war fand ich sie fantastisch
die leute kommen hierher nur um
mitzufeiern
das ist teil
der freizeit aspekt ist gut doch der
schiffsverkehr geht fuhr und die flut
steigt nil und henry müssen noch das
hydraulische system im vorderen teil des
auslegers checken
[Musik]
wenn das nicht funktioniert kann die
brücke nicht ablegen
der hydraulik antrieb setzt die
druckzylinder am äußeren ende in gang
eng viel stahl viele rohre hier im
ausleger fühlt man sich fast wie in
einem u boot
wir machen hier sichtkontrollen sind die
leitungen in ordnung sind die
verschraubungen dicht aber die sind alle
sauber
platzangst darf man hier hinten nicht
haben
die brücke läuft zum ende ja immer
spitzer zu für uns arbeiter wird es da
immer enger aber man kann sich daran
gewöhnen das innenleben der brücke ist
fast genauso komplex wie ihr
bewegungsmechanismus
drei druckzylinder senken das ende der
ausleger plattform ab dadurch hebt sich
das andere ende der brücke so wird sie
drei beziehungsweise schwenkbar drei
elektromotoren schwenken sie mit einer
geschwindigkeit von etwas über einem
halben meter pro sekunde in 100 sekunden
ist die brücke komplett geöffnet nach
den ersten betriebsjahren zeigen sich
erste abnutzungserscheinungen
doch verschleiß ist normal bei
beweglichen brücken die lebenserwartung
dieser brücke sollte schon 150 jahre
betragen
natürlich müssen wir dieser zeit die
brücke warten das große lager muss
ausgetauscht werden das hält nur 50
jahre die hydraulik und die software
werden sich schon verändern aber die
ganze konstruktion hält 150 jahre und
das ist sicherlich nach meiner
pensionierung
im fluss steht das wasser mittlerweile
hoch genug das tankschiff wartet bereits
auf die durchfahrt
bridge operator dienst essens bereitet
das öffnen der brücke vor den befehl
dafür gibt er per fernbedienung von
außen
okay das ganze dauert jetzt 5
wichtig vor jeder öffnung nichts darf
dem bereich vor dem zugang blockieren
tankschiff und passanten warten darauf
dass es losgeht
die wirbelsäule des brückenbogens dreht
mit hilfe des elektrischen antriebs
mechanismus seine zentralen zapfen die
ring schiene die drehgestelle und die
hydraulikleitungen in ihrem auskragenden
abschnitt sind alle unter deck
im fundament überwachten in wales die
funktion der frisch geschmierte noll
räder das schmatzende geräusche bedeutet
alles bestens
nur noch wenige sekunden und das
tankschiff kann passieren
[Musik]
drei minuten später ist das spektakel
vorbei die brücke und ihre besucher
können wieder zurückfahren
und genau das ist es was die scale wayne
bridge so einzigartig macht
aus passanten werden passagiere
so das war's selbst wenn die skyline
ridge ruth sieht sie aus als sei sie
gerade auf dem sprung eine dynamische
konstruktion und einer der
spektakulärsten beweglichen brücken der
welt